[Music]
need I'm a monotheist girl I'm a
monotheist no you're not yes I am I
believe in one God I just have a
different concept of the one God than
you do I believe that the one God is
Triune you believe that the one God is a
Unitarian God meaning he's only one
person within his Essence I believe that
the one God is three persons within his
essence
hello hi been a
while voice what you doing up so late
this is 12:18 not so late I usually
sleep late actually so yeah okay cool
what do you want to say I was just going
to ask you know sometimes I come to your
live sometimes I comment sometimes I
come up and you know I was just like
like the other brothers said and then
you had to play like a voice note or
somebody saying that uh um you actually
know a lot about Islam I'm going to
actually give you that because it takes
someone to know something about
something to be able to you know rise up
and start arguing about it cting and you
know bringing some texture or whatever
out of it however I think that um what
you do as much as you do it like to
justify your belief I think that you
Cherry like kind of like cherry speak to
assertain or just to confirm whatever
you're trying to um communicate to
others but I was just going to ask you
like sincerely like in sincerity after
studying the Quran I'm not sure you did
a full study I know okay if you did then
you know why don't you take the Quran in
like in its entir why do you just Pi you
know some wordss just to confirm um The
Script scures and to confirm the Torah
you know just so that you because if if
you're bringing all this evidence from
the Quran like it's almost like you're
actually supporting that claim just so
that you can you know affirm that your
scripture is is what it is and honestly
as a Muslim we believe in the Torah and
we believe also in the inil but the
problem that you have cuz she always
kind of bring the verse out that okay
those of you that actually Chic out of
like the scripture believing that the
scripture is the word of God if you
Cherry PE you know and then say Oh this
is good this is bad because I I look at
that as that's what you you actually do
to the Quran you Cherry peek aside from
Cherry peing then you give it your own
meaning exactly what the Quran is saying
that you know people kind of twist the
words just to you know satisfy you know
whatever they're trying to project out
but if you like as a person own heart no
I'm I'm not asking a question I'm not
here for debate I'm just I just I said I
wanted to talk to you I don't know
whether you saw my comments I didn't get
to say anything you said what when am I
when am I going to get to say something
well I'm still commenting you
have I mean I'm just trying to you know
voice out my um suggestion and whatever
I have in my mind to
you so basically you're telling me not
to take the Quran out of context just to
support my narrative just to support
your narrative then aside from that I
was also going to tell you to actually
also be a better like servant of God
because if you truly believe in God and
like you study the go um the gospel and
the Torah and then you actually open the
Quran then you shouldn't then you should
merge it together because I as a person
I might not necessarily fit into the
like idea or clich Muslim that oh I
don't believe in Torah I personally if
you want to ask for my view I think
because my mom is a Christian so I don't
really kind of segregate but I do
believe that even if you're a Christian
and you follow Christianity to the core
you wouldn't be on the wrong path
because that's actually also the path of
God because the scripture came before
the Quran and the Quran made us
understand that those that actually like
studied scripture those that actually
follow the scripture and um the Torah to
the core they not actually on the wrong
excuse me something now can I jump in
and say something well you can say
something I'm just um just painting my
opinion it's not I know I know you're so
what I would say in response to that is
number one I don't take the Quran out of
his context I don't I know what the
Quran says on a certain subject in fool
and I never take it out of its context I
we we as Christians at least the you
know the ones who are intellectually
honest we we have this uh thing about us
where we have to read books in their
context is what we do with the Bible so
we're going to do the same thing with
the Quran because we can't stand when
Muslims come to our Bible and they pluck
verses out of the context what they like
and dislike so we don't do that okay so
I would say and that's majority of us so
I don't do that I take the Quran as a
whole like if we're talking about does
the Quran affirm the Bible I take what
the Quran says on that subject as a
whole and I have come to a conclusion on
what it says and my conclusion is as a
whole when you look at everything in the
Quran says on this topic the answer is
yes it confirms the Bible and I present
that know that's all now it's not that I
support that view like I'm saying that
the Quran is is a true book no that's a
problem that it confirms the Bible
because the Bible says things that the
Quran contradicts so then that makes the
Quran false for that okay so the subject
of um confirmation of the um Bible the
Bible okay for example but I know that
it explicitly says in the Quran oh sorry
says in the Quran scripture and Torah
not exactly Bible
so if like in sincerity to yourself
because I know that even Christian
Scholars they do say that there's been
some distorion some additions or
whatsoever I personally yeah I haven't
sat down to like you know start looking
at the scripture I'm looking at which
was added you know I don't really have
Christians don't say that there's
additions and subtractions they don't
say that so what do they say Christians
believe that the Bible is preserved they
understand that there's textual variance
in certain man manuscripts but
Christians understand that textual
variance does not equal corruption so we
believe that we have God's word
preserved with the Revelation that he
wanted to give us the writings of the
prophets the gospel and stuff like that
we have it we have everything we need
and more is what Christian Scholars say
okay so what's the textual variance is
it in like words so whates the textural
variance exactly yes so like there are
there are like for example there are
some manuscripts that have survived
better than other manuscripts so some
manuscripts are only pieces while other
manuscripts would be a little Fuller
piece or maybe a whole copy right um and
so certain manuscripts may not have the
same verses that are on another
manuscript in full or something like
that or there might be a manuscript
compared to another manuscript that may
have double copied a verse you can tell
that the copy you describe mistakenly
may have wrote the same verse twice you
know while another manuscript only has
it once that's a variant you know um so
like you have a lot of you have stuff
like that none of the variants you have
some of that are meaningful you know um
like there's a manuscript that that
doesn't have the like like for example
the ending of Mark some some manuscripts
don't have the longer ending of Mark
some of them stop at like verse eight I
believe it is um but we have both that's
the thing those are variance but we have
everything we're we're not missing
anything you know if Mark ended with a
longer ending we have it if Mark only
ended with a shorter ending we have it
we're not missing nothing okay so would
you would you say like with your um test
or would you testify that the Bible that
you carrying right now both the Old and
the New Testament is exactly the same as
it should have been like or maybe the
initial manuscript or whatever it is is
it the same thing like I'm going to say
right now with my chest that this what
I'm holding look at me this you see me
this what I'm holding is preserved okay
it is preserved it so what we take what
we mean by preservation we believe that
the message is preserved you know so we
don't have every word doesn't have to be
exactly the same we don't believe in
that we don't believe word for word
letter for letter everything has to be
exactly that's not what we believe the
message and the theme is preserved it's
consistent and so it is it's unchanged
that's what we mean by it's preserved
okay I hear you but um you said you
actually look at the Quran and like it's
in its full entirety yeah what did you
think about the concept of God being a
monotheistic god without you know the
Trinity I'm a monotheist girl I'm a
monotheist no you're not yes I am I
believe in one God I just have a
different concept of the one God than
you do I believe that the one God is
Triune you believe that the one God is a
Unitarian God meaning he's only one
person within his Essence I believe that
the one God is three persons within his
Essence but we're both monotheists yeah
so that's where the problem comes in
because once you see that the God God is
three persons in one that is when you're
already adding three persons three
entity to become one that's the problem
that's right no you're not adding
anything I'm I'm only showing I'm only
believing in what God revealed to me in
the scripture God revealed to me that he
is one Essence one nature and that three
persons all have this one Divine Essence
not three different entities not three
different gods three persons that share
one Essence that's what we believe but
but would you say that is what's like
the entirety of the um Bible is is
saying without a doubt it's so clear
it's clear as day without without
understanding that the Bible won't make
sense it won't well because there was a
day that you actually quoted it but I
think IED it somewhere I was like well
you well you just read this out this
makes sense to me and I don't know why
you like you didn't like um interpret it
in that manner in say you interpret I'm
trying to look for the verse I think it
was about I think I wrot it somewhere um
if I could find it I think you picked it
from the um the Bible you I don't know
what I was maybe 14 I don't know but I
can't really remember but I wrote it
somewhere is it where Jesus says I am in
the father and the father's in me no not
that one it was you sure was that one no
no no not that one because but that that
would be a verse where Jesus is saying
he's God right when he says the father's
in him and he's in the father yeah that
would mean yeah yeah that would me that
would automatically you know TI off your
trium you know idea but there was a
verse that you about submission of um
Jesus to God and you know I think you
were you actually listed it wasn't just
one you listed like four four different
chapters or so you were just there
there's quite a few verses there's quite
a few verses where Jesus submits to the
father it takes the role of a humble
servant yes so yeah so I'm like so why
why when you can read that from your um
from your Bible then why do you doesn't
that um contradict the concept of like
God being a three entity and also being
we don't believe that he's three
entities so please use the terminology
that I'm giving
you three persons one what's the
difference it's the same thing now no
the difference is that when you say
three different entities that's three
different gods three different beings
three different Natures three different
Essences so we don't believe in three
different entities we believe in one
entity one Divine Essence what about the
three person so what makes it difference
so what the three person what does it
connote the three persons what what is
the three persons you said I should use
the term three persons so person a
person personhood is like it's it's the
who a being is so you have like for
example so your being your nature your
being or your entity is your state of
existence it's what you are like you are
a human being right God is a Divine
being okay um personhood is who you are
so I don't know your name sis but
whoever you are that's who you are
you're a human being and the who you are
that's who you are me I'm a human being
the person that I am is Avery I am Avery
and I'm a human being one human being
one human person with God we're saying
that God is one Divine being but he has
three persons three who's the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit share that same
Divine Essence okay one what what he is
he's God Divine Essence Divine being who
is he he is the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit three persons yeah so okay I
understand the person's idea now but
then that doesn't still like um give a
tick off to the idea of you know Jesus
being subservient to God and you know to
me that that contradicts the idea of a
god oh it it shouldn't because you know
God is the most virtuous being in all of
existence he's virtuous right every he
has every good quality wouldn't you
agree I mean you that means you're
putting God in the
um you know should I say you're putting
him in in in a characteristics of a
human being you know no these are the
these are characteristics that humans
get from God these aren't human
characteristics God's characteristics
that we borrow you get what I'm saying
all all of this stuff comes from God
humility humil humility love patience
Mercy Justice all of this comes from God
these AR human qualities yeah but humans
as Ste humans commit adultery humans do
crime so yeah those things those things
are of of humanity but every good the
Bible says this in in the Book of James
every good thing comes from God so every
virtu is characteristic every good thing
that's from God it's not from man so
what about the bad things what happen
that's from that's from man's evil
inclinations and sin okay so now now
that we've ascertained that that's human
quality right mhm now the fact that
Jesus is a man he he's a human and is
subservient to a God yeah it doesn't
still like it hasn't still made much
sense to me well it's like it's it's
like this um if you're at work and you
have a boss you will be subservient to
your boss right but that doesn't mean
that you are not human like your boss is
human okay it just means that in a
certain C
you willfully are subservient to your
boss you take a servant's role to your
boss while you and your boss are still
human y'all have the same like nature so
similarly Jesus Takes the role of a
servant he willfully you know submits
his will to the father but that doesn't
mean that he and the father don't have
the same nature as God him submitting
doesn't take away that he is God just
like the father is God he just no no
that contradicted because once you agree
that somebody is higher than you the
reason why you're submitting why are we
submitting to God is because we believe
that he's higher than us because it's
because we believe he created us so for
you to have the submissive Act of
submitting to God that's all that's all
it takes to serve God we are serving God
that's that's the point the point is
you're serving a God so if Jesus can
serve a God that's that's all that's all
we need okay so let me ask you this then
does God own everything yes okay so can
he inherit anything inherit I don't
think inherit is the right word he
creates everything I I agree with you
that God since he owns everything
wouldn't be able to inherit anything
because he owns everything to inherit
means to receive something that's not
yours right okay but the Quran says this
over and over again the Quran says that
Allah is the best of inheritors it's one
of his names so if Allah is the owner of
everything which is also one of his
names how is it that he is the best of
inheritors receiving something that's
not his and from who is he inheriting
from well I cannot argue that because I
really don't understand the context of
that but context of what I understand is
the context of we serving God and that
is like the the claim that I'm bringing
forward I don't really understand all
this because I'm not really into
religion religion do you understand I'm
not really like a religious religious
person that does you know go into the
old whatever of the Quran but I do have
like a basic understanding of serving
God and understanding that God is one
and that this this is what this is the
reason why I brought this up the reason
why I brought this up is because you
have a view of of of God that he can't
do certain things um he is too high to
do certain things and to this idea of
God for example hum huming himself is
out of the question for
you you know why I wouldn't agree to
that because God himself said it because
I believe one and that he doesn't beget
doesn't um what's it called doesn't be
no son then I might agree with you do
you understand but if God says this like
this is my quality this is my
characteristics then we cannot assign
then okay so my so that's my problem if
God tells us that he has a humble about
himself a gentle quality about himself
who are you to say that when God the son
humbles himself and serves the father
that that's a problem that that it's
that that contradicts his nature it
doesn't he tells us that that's a
quality of his of him so just like you
wouldn't have you wouldn't say that
Allah's not God anymore because he
inherits things because there are things
that he doesn't own that he then
receives you that's a quality of his you
don't you you're oh okay Allah whatever
you say so have that same energy for
when I'm telling you who God is in the
Christian Christian realm God has the
quality in the virtue of of humility I
understand okay I understand the con
concept of humility but God serving God
himself like God serving God does
doesn't make sense do you understand it
only makes
sense it only it only makes it only
makes sense if God is a trinity if God
is multi-person if he's more than one
person then it makes sense if one of the
persons decided to Humble himself and
serve the other that's that it'll make
sense in that life but if God is only
one person he's absolutely one one
person then of course it wouldn't make
sense for God to serve God like that
makes that's impossible that makes no
sense so have when you're thinking of
this think of it in you know the lens
that I'm giving you that God is triumph
that the nature of God is shared by
three persons so one of the persons
decides to Humble himself and serve the
other it doesn't take away from his
divinity okay so now why is it the other
way around why is it Jesus being the one
subservient to the father and not the
father subservient to the son why why is
it that way be because that's the role
of the son the son is the one who's
begotten from the father and creation
and all these things are for the son God
has orchestrated these things for the
son and his love for the son and so the
son since creation belongs to him and is
made for him in honor of him it's upon
him and his responsibility to save
creation to represent man kind because
we can't represent ourselves before the
father so Jesus comes as our
representative in serving the father
perfectly in the way that we couldn't
and he lives the life that we should
have lived for the father in a way that
we couldn't and he gives us his
righteousness he takes off his
righteousness and gives it to us so that
we can be appear righteous before the
father so that's why Jesus Takes that
role of the servant for us okay for us I
I like the father I said for us but the
point is he made a point of God humbling
himself right and then you know one can
serve one another I mean like a tri on
God so if they can serve one another and
you know they do accept themselves as
God if one can bow for what for then the
other should also be able to Bow if one
can say you know I'm the father there's
an authority somewhere that says I'm the
father then that authority of the father
is higher than that of the son
automatically do you understand what I'm
saying cannot bow to the son so that
means that power or that Authority is
not the same thing so you cannot equate
well think of it this way you have the
father well you have the son who honors
and worships and glorifies the Father
the father does the same thing for the
son he honors glorifies and worships the
son too he calls the son Lord who
created all things who made the heavens
and the Earth and how he will never
change while everything else will fade
away he Remains the Same the father says
that about the son he calls him God so
the father worships honors glorifies and
adores the son just like the son does
the same thing for the father it's
mutual not get to my question my
question is more about adoring um you
know giving praises and all that that's
that's okay I'm okay with that but the
point is the father is not serving the
son that's not his role exactly so
that's that's that's the point I'm
trying to make is not his role to serve
the son so if the son can serve the
father that means he subservient to his
father and that is the point of religion
and that's the point of serving God we
are all going to serve God once you
serve a God you are God that's the point
that what I'm saying I I I I I
understand what you're saying but except
you're still not getting it you're
acting as if serving or humility takes
away from Jesus's divine nature you're
saying oh because Jesus serves the
father that means he's not God serving
someone doesn't take away from your
nature if you serve your boss that
doesn't mean you're not human anymore
that he's a serving God doesn't mean
he's not God anymore okay I agree so
that means the father too should be able
to have the son and because it wouldn't
he he could but that's not his role it's
not that he can't it's not his role how
do you know that's not his role if you
say because the scripture because the
scripture reveals to us what the son's
role is what the spirit's role is and
what the father's role is the son is the
one who takes the role of the servant
not the father we're just showing you
what the persons do you get it the
scriptures reveal to us that the son
willfully takes the servant role it
doesn't take doesn't mean he's not God
anymore he just decides to serve and
humble himself by his choice so as a
Christian that you have what is your
purpose as a Christian my purpose is to
serve God and make him known to others
so what's the difference between you and
Jesus I'm not I'm not God but you're
performing the rule of Jesus Jesus told
me to do that okay yeah Jesus told me to
go out and make disciples in his name
and spread the gospel okay the point is
you already made a point that Jesus rule
is to serve God I agree with you but
you're on that's that's hold on you're
you're over you're like sticking to one
thing that I said that's not all that
Jesus is is is supposed to do you're ask
you're asking about about why did he
serve he took the servants role to serve
and humble himself before the father and
he does that not just in love for the
father but for our sake he did it he did
it for our sake that's why he comes to
Earth and represents Us in human form
that's why he does that every do you
don't you know I don't know am I
pronouncing your name right is it Avery
right it's Avery yeah okay so you know
you know um what I'm trying to actually
do here is not I'm not actually debating
I'm just trying to put the idea that if
like you said you know Jesus according
to you Jesus gave you those rules or
probably came over to you know save you
or you know I don't know die for you cuz
I really don't like to use that word you
know die for you to save you from God
so my question will now be are you
trying to say that God is not in his own
self now the father I mean the father
now are you saying that he doesn't have
the capability to forgive you or save
you you know outside Jesus or you know
what I don't know well I get what you're
saying um and and here's your answer
that God has set a system a justice
system where the wage or the price of
sin is death eternal separation from God
that's what spiritual is
death you get that from the Bible the
Bible says in Romans 5 that the price of
sin the wages of sin is death so but you
know everyone dies at the end of the day
because Jesus also died I mean there's
multiple kinds of death you have
physical death and you also have
spiritual death by when we come into
faith in Christ we are spiritually
regenerated right before before we
believe in the Messiah without him we
remain spiritually dead in our sin but
when we come into belief of the Messiah
we are now regenerated spiritually and
we're spiritually alive again we're
alive in the spirit and reconnected with
God so that even in this Mortal body we
may die before he comes but some living
in their mortal body when he comes they
will be transformed with a new body that
will never cease it will never die but
um so even though we may die physically
in the this Mortal body we are
spiritually alive with God and we will
return with him in heaven we'll be with
him right so spiritual death is the
price of sin not just it's both physical
death and spiritual death death as a
whole you have physical death and
spiritual death both is the price of sin
spiritual death is worse though because
spiritually you are now separed from God
that's what it means to be spiritually
dead SE death is like separation so
you're separated from God right and you
will be separated from God for eternity
if you die in your sins right so that is
why since the price of sin is death it
the debt had to be paid the punishment
the price had to be paid according to
God's justice and so that's why God in
the person of the son takes on a mortal
body that he can die in for the sake of
humanity and pay the price for us
because we can't do it ourselves okay so
you know you where we try to apply logic
here the logic is still not logic sorry
to say that's like if you say I'm trying
to put everything that you're saying
together because I'm trying to learn
from you as much as I'm trying to give
you what I I have to say I'm trying to
also understand like where you're coming
from but I'm trying to like I'm trying
to add Pierce into what you're saying
but I'm not really getting it so now
what you're trying to say is that um so
that you could be spiritually saved
Jesus had to die is that what you're
saying say that again I mean you said
said so that you can be spiritually
saved Jesus had to die that's what
you're saying right yeah that was the
price so my point is why does Jesus have
to pray the price why Jesus because he's
the only one who can if we did it we
would die in our sins and face God's
Wrath but Jesus was the only one who
could take on the wrath of God the
punishment and overcome right wouldn't
that be an unjust like U way that
totally like that's not Justice if you
were is it is it would it be would it be
is it unjust if you commit a crime in
the courtroom and you have a bail find
of a million dollars it's either you
spend 20 years in jail for your crime or
you come up with a million dollars to
pay your bail fine so that you can go
free is it unjust if someone comes into
the courtroom and pays the million
dollars for you gives you the money to
pay it is that unjust I mean if I have
to pay that money the point is I'm
trying to undo my wrongs right trying to
pay for your wrongs yeah I'm trying to
pay for my wrongs okay so so this this
is the way you pay for your wrong either
you pay the a million dollars or you go
to jail for 20 years okay is it unjust
if someone comes in the courtroom and
pays the million dollar fine for you so
that you can go free is that unjust well
I wouldn't really say it's unjust good
that means the person is paying on my
behalf right exactly
so the same way we are in God's
courtroom we are guilty of a crime or
guilty of sin and our sentence is death
unless someone comes in and pays the
fine for us that's when Jesus walks into
the courtroom and says don't worry I got
it and he pays the fine for us okay I
get that but you know it will be unjust
you know that is just like um when it
comes like payment and all of that but
now let's take let's take the other part
of the punishment which is the 20 years
in prisonment do you understand so would
it be would it not be unjust for that
same person to um go to prison instead
of me not if that's in according with
the law years imprisonment instead of me
because I mean the $20 or whatever the
amounts that you just mentioned it's
just in terms of material things and
it's not matter of fact you actually
have cases like this where um where a
person trades thems to be to be held in
prison instead of their guilty party
that they love they say take me hold
hold me prisoner and let them free you
know and I'll do the time that's the
crime is being paid for justice being
served and so is love being given out
love is being displayed but now you know
that would have been if it was like
something that was willing from the
person's end I mean the person said take
me you know I can do this the person is
submitting himself to that right it's
not judge that is saying oh pick this
guy hope he going to serve on their
right you're you're absolutely right so
what you have here is Jesus this is what
Jesus says he says this in John chapter
10 hold on a second in John chapter 10
Jesus says he says I am the Good
Shepherd I know my own and my own know
me just as the father knows me and I
know the father and I lay down my life
for the Sheep he says and I have other
sheep that are not of this fold I must
bring them also and they will listen to
my voice so there will be one flock and
one shepherd He says for this reason the
father loves me because I lay down my
life that I might take it up again no
one takes it from me but I lay it down
on my own accord I have the authority to
lay it down and I have the authority to
pick it back up again this charge I have
received from my father so Jesus lets us
know that he willingly comes and he lays
down his life for the Sheep which is one
of the reasons why the father loves him
okay so what you just write to me now is
what what what chapter and what this is
John chapter 10 verse 14 to
18 John chapter
10 what you call it I don't know how you
call your
things sorry I don't John 10 verse 14
to8
14 okay so in context of what was this
what was the scenario what was the
scenario here is that Jesus is saying
that he is willingly laying down his
life okay that was the context of what
was happening in that verse right okay
but because what I what I understand and
I think I know from like way before was
that when the crucifixion was going to
take place or I don't know you can
correct me this is just like a broad
knowledge it's not really exactly
specific um I do know that they did say
that Jesus cried and you know asked God
to um come to his help wouldn't that you
know contradict this particular
statement because if somebody is crying
and saying save me have you forsaken me
and all of that that's not willingly
anymore no it doesn't contradict that
and here's why because one he's saying
my God my God why have you forsaken me
he's quoting Psalm 22 and you've been
you've seen my life so you probably seen
me present this before but he's quoting
a Psalm he's quoting a prophecy that's
about him so we go to Psalm 22 and we
see what Jesus is quoting we see the
context of it Psalm 22 it literally
starts off with my God my God why have
you forsaken why are you so far from
saving me from the words of my Gro right
and then he can he goes down verse seven
all who see me mock me they make mouths
of me they wag their heads he trusts in
the Lord let him deliver him let him
rescue him for he Delights in him he
says down in verse 13 14 I am poured out
like water all my bones are out of joint
my heart is like Wax it is melted within
my breast my strength is dried up like a
pot shirt and my tongue sticks to my
jaws you lay me in the dust of death for
dogs Encompass me a company of evildoers
encircles me listen they have pierced my
hands and my feet this is Psalm 22 that
Jesus is quoting a thousand years before
he's born they have pierce my hands and
my feet I can count all my bones they
stare and they gloat over me they divide
my garments among them and for my
clothing they cast lots they gamble over
his clothes that's what they had what
had what the Roman soldiers did at the
crucifixion okay so the reason why Jesus
is crying this out or quoting this Psalm
is because the Jews that's around him
when he quotes the very first verse of
the psalm they will they will know what
he's quoting because they memorize it
they recite the Psalms ssongs are songs
that they recite all the time in the
temple so they recite it and they would
understand and recognize what he's
quoting and when they go back to the
psalm they will see that Psalm 22 was a
prophecy about the crucifixion about
what happened to him okay so let me get
this so that I don't misunderstand what
you trying to tell me so you're saying
that the psalm this particular um
chapter and verse they just read to me
now was um was like a prophecy is that
what you're saying absolutely so when
was this when did Jesus say this
particular um Jesus said it when he was
on the cross he he quoted the psalm when
he was on the cross my God my God why
have you forsaken me that that lying
that Jesus quot Cries Out is quoting
Psalm 22 Psalm 22 literally the very
first verse is my God my God why have
you forsaken me why are you so far from
saving me and then it continues talking
about his crucifixion and what's going
on how people are mocking him how people
surround him and they're abusing him you
know wait wait wait I think I'm not
getting something I think I'm probably
misunderstanding you because if you say
it's a prophecy why is it then isn't say
something that's supposed to happen
happen in the future if you say on the
cross why is it then a prophecy because
the pongs comes a thousand years before
the birth of Jesus so a thousand years
before the crucifixion the psalm was
already written about the crucifixion oh
okay I get your point now okay so you're
saying this particular um verse has been
already before Jesus that's what you're
saying and so he just quoted that verse
on the cross is that what you're saying
yes you got it so this particular Psalms
that you qued so who wrote it before
Jesus oh okay okay okay I think I get
what you're trying to say now all right
so you're saying this is not um Jesus
directly saying his words so basically
he's
putting um the words the psalm words of
the PSAL okay to uh make the people know
know the crucifixion am I right I don't
know what you're trying to another the
prophecy okay okay I mean I hear you but
you hear me yeah I hear you because I
mean it's not as if I'm going to change
your ideology of night but I just know
that if Allah truly wants to guide you
right he will and is not my Jesus has
already gued me sister I mean that's
fine I believe like if you truly follow
the gospel like your scripture to the
call I mean they are Unitarian
Christians right I mean if you do that
there are no Unitarian Christians there
are people I mean I see them on Tik Tok
yeah they're not Christians they are
I've seen them they they quote the Bible
you're missing what I'm saying okay
they're not Christians you have to be a
trinitarian to be a Christian these
people who reject the Trinity who reject
the deity of Christ they are not
Christians that's like somebody
disbelieving claiming to be a Muslim and
saying Muhammad's not a prophet it's
similar to that you hear what I'm saying
well I mean it's because because I think
your idea I think the thing is the
ideology is different but if they're
also quoting from the same text and
they're also like justifying what I mean
it's it's the same text right you're
you're not listening I am listening to
you anybody can quote from the same text
that doesn't make them part of that
belief so I'm saying what I'm trying to
say is that what what is that full
Authority I mean it's 50/50 here let's
let's be real there is not 50-50 you
have 2000 years wrong right I need you
to listen we have 2,000 years of church
history that has already have been
established Christianity for 2,000 years
and we have seen these Heretics rise up
even throughout the generations and
they've been d destroyed by the Bishops
and the church fathers who use the
scripture to expose them and they die
off and then they come back hundreds of
years later then die off again and come
back hundreds of years later then they
die off again literally we have 2,000
years of church history with established
doctrine that points out what a
Christian is and what isn't so these
people who go against the Trinity who
say Jesus is not God they go against
2,000 years of established Christianity
they're not Christians okay I hear you
but what I'm trying to say is that you
know the fact that they have been
destroyed and all of that that's not
really a proof that they were not true
Christians it could be that um the
people that it could you know politics
is involved in everything and um if they
the bad people had the higher power of
course they use their power to destroy
you know I mean Satan can plot and he
can do whatever he needs to do to
project the bad whatever out there and
make people believe falsely in in in the
message and make them think it's true so
because those set of people were
destroyed doesn't mean that they were
wrong they could be the right set of
people and probably I'm not saying 100%
but I mean probably you're actually like
following what's the false message and
the right ones were the ones that were
destroyed I'm just saying just in quotes
you understand so you saying I don't I
don't I don't I don't care what what
you're saying about that I I follow the
scriptures I'm in line with the
scriptures and I'm in line with church
history I know that you're a Muslim so
as a Muslim you have your biases and you
are saying that true Christianity be
like because the Quran says that
Christians are right and that the Bible
is true like the Tor and of gospel so
true Christianity can't they can't teach
that Jesus is God they can't be
trinitarian as a Muslim I can't allow I
can't allow myself to believe that
because that brings a problem for the
Quran I know why you have the position
you do but I am telling you that what
you need to do is try to separate
yourself and I know it's hard to do this
for anyone try to separate yourself from
an Islamic lens if you're talking about
Christianity okay separate yourself from
Islam okay and look at Christianity
objectively okay look at what
Christianity has been for 2,000 years
since Jesus look at the scripture and
what it says objectively aside from your
lens as a Muslim look at it that way and
and that's what I encourage you to do
okay all right yeah yeah well um I think
what what I what I was trying to say is
because I know that um was it I'm not of
course now you know that I really don't
know the scriptures but I do pick from
here and here and I know that um they
did say that Jesus said that there would
be like a false um prophets coming and
then there'll be many of them many false
prophets coming he says okay I mean we
still have so many people claiming to
the prophet but today Muhammad was one
of them very F Muhammad was one of them
and yet he confirm your scripture yeah
that that that was that was that was a
foolish move he wanted he wanted the
Jews and the Christians to believe he
was a
prophet he wanted them to believe that
so he told them hey I I'm I'm in line
with what you have unaware that he's his
stuff contradicts what they have or
maybe he maybe he did know that well I
mean if you want to argue that you can
go ahead and argue that because I mean
point is um the true message of God will
still be the true message of God whether
you agree to it or not and um you I mean
you listen to it you talk about it you
have evidence of it right in front of
you every day and I believe prophecy my
sister I believe the prophets you don't
I can only I do I believe the prophets
then why don't then why don't you
believe Prophet David when he foretold
the crucifixion why don't you believe
him so did I say I don't know about
crucifixion I know that somebody was
crucified but I don't believe that the
person that was crucified died for my
sin so that's what the prophets say the
prophets say that the person who's being
pierced is doing that for your sins
Isaiah 53 Isaiah the prophet 700 years
before the crucifixion says he bore the
sin of many and was numbered with the
transgressors that because of him our
sins are wiped away that his soul is a
guilt offering a sin offering that's
what Isaiah 53 says so this is where the
belief system comes in first of all I
don't I do not believe that somebody
died for my sin I believe but the
prophets this is why I say you don't
believe the prophets let me finish my
statement I believe that God is capable
of forgiving my sins without human
sacrifice he doesn't need it I believe
in all the prophets and I the scriptures
from you don't believe in the prophets
when you just reject the listen to me
yeah so however even though I believe in
the prophets whatever whatever is in the
Torah whatever is in the gospel as to
match up with what my um what's it
called by should I say um cor belief is
which is yeah you're saying that the
prophets have to line up with what you
think as a Muslim not what no no not
what I'm thinking yeah it has to line up
with the word of God because as a Muslim
I wait wait a second are the prophets
words the word of God yes okay so if
anything contradicts with the prophet
the prophets are revealing the word of
God my sister the prophets are revealing
the word of God you are rejecting what
the prophets say so you're rejecting the
word of God okay so this is it now this
is the hierarchy of it the only reason
why I'm believing in the prophet is
because my Quran told me too so I'm
believing first of all in the word of
God so the first thing first is I'm
believing the commands of I'm believing
the Quran that is my first but you don't
your Quran tells you to believe what the
prophet say which I do and my Quran also
makes me believe that Allah is one and
so whatever contradicts that message are
you listening I am listening if you
listen to me let me finish my stat no no
because you're wasting my time your
Quran tells you that to believe in the
prophets I just read you versus from the
prophets and you reject them so you're
not even following the commands of your
Quran
what you you just read a verse about
David said um um Jesus was going to be
crucified and die for my sin I reject
that because first of all I don't even
know the ensity of that word that you're
saying that the Quran the Quran says
that he gave the Psalms to David what do
you mean you don't know the authenticity
of it your Quran says it's God's words
okay so if it says that then it has to
automatically like align with the core
message of Oneness of God if it doesn't
your for your Quran to be true this this
will be it because you're wasting my
time for the Quran to be true for the
pay attention for the Quran to be true
it has to line up with what the prophet
say no that's that's not it for the to
be true it's too late for me
this we spoke long enough we spoke it's
fine I mean I I can't pass my message so
not take care of yourself have a good
night